Speaker 1: Last night, as the missiles were
raining down in Ukraine from Russia, Kiev
all over the country as Russian troops were
pouring in from Belarus and in from Crimea
and over into the Donetsk and Luhansk.
As all of this is happening, Trump goes on.
Fox News is interviewed by Laura Ingraham
and says this all happened because of the
rigged up of the election.
I mean, guys.
Let's just listen.
Speaker 4: Look, probably ever we're independent
and in blue.
Speaker 5: We're just we're just learning
that U.S. officials are looking at a potential
amphibious landing now in Odessa, Ukraine,
again a month ago or three weeks ago, all
the so-called experts were saying that, you
know, Putin was probably going to just be
content with staying in those separatist regions.
But I think given what's unfolded, sadly with
a lot of weakness in the United States, they
just decided to go for it, right?
Speaker 1: So Laura tees it up and says Putin
probably is so like they were so wrong about
the intelligence.
These people, we had all the intelligence
like, it really looks like they're planning
an invasion.
They're like, No, no, no, no, no.
And now they're saying, Well, we were wrong,
but because we didn't think the U.S. would
be so weak to cause the invasion, and Trump
just tease that, you know, she tees it up
and Trump hits it out of the park.
As far as they're concerned,
Speaker 5: it looks like they're going for
it.
And where does that leave the Nieto alliance?
Speaker 4: I think you're exactly right.
I think that's what happened.
Who is going to be satisfied with a beast?
And now he sees the weakness and the incompetence
and the stupidity of this administration and
as an American.
Angry about it.
And I'm saddened by it.
And it all happened because of a rigged election.
This would have never happened.
And that includes inflation.
And that includes millions of people pouring
in on a monthly basis, far more than three
million people.
And they're coming from 129 different countries.
Speaker 1: Wait a second.
So Putin's invading Russia because you falsely
believe the election was stolen from you and
undocumented immigrants from Latin America
are coming to the United States.
This is a bizarre foreign policy analysis.
Speaker 4: I have no idea what's happening
and they're destroying our country.
Speaker 5: President Trump, we actually have
just hold on.
I'm so sorry to interrupt you, but we have.
We're going to.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they're going to something.
So moments later.
This is this is just incredible.
Moments later, Trump seems to think that Laura
Ingraham told him that the U.S. has launched
an attack on Ukraine and Trump's like, you
shouldn't have said that.
And Laura Ingraham has to say No, no, no.
The Russians launched an amphibious attack
on Ukraine, guys.
Trump seems to think that the story is the
U.S. invaded, invaded Ukraine.
I.
Speaker 5: Monitor this continuing to monitor
his statements.
We'll go back to President Trump for a quick
reaction.
We had a kind of a really pathetic display
from the Ukrainian President Zelensky earlier
today, President Trump, where he in Russian.
He doesn't like to speak Russian, but in Russian,
he was essentially imploring Vladimir Putin
not to invade his country.
And now we basically have the Ukrainian ambassador
to the United Nation Nations looking like
a defeated man.
Speaker 1: All right.
You guys ready for this?
Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Your final reaction?
Speaker 4: Well, I think the whole thing again
would have never happened.
It shouldn't happen.
And it's a very sad thing.
But you know, what's also very dangerous is
you told me about the amphibious attacks by
Americans.
You shouldn't be saying that because you and
everybody else should know about it.
They should do that secretly not be doing
that through the great Laura Ingram.
They should be doing this secretly.
You should know that, Laura,
Speaker 5: and you know, that was the Russians.
Now those are the Russian, the Russian amphibious.
Speaker 4: I thought you said, I thought you
said that you were sending people.
Speaker 3: No, no, no.
The U.S. officials.
Speaker 1: She said U.S. officials, you know,
are seeing that there's an amphibious attack
happening.
Imagine being so dazed and clueless that in
the midst of Russia invading Ukraine and the
U.S. clearly being on the side that Russia
is in the wrong, as a former president, you
believe that what's happening is the U.S.
has launched an amphibious attack and invasion
of Ukraine.
Guys, we're screwed.
We're screwed.
Here's one last very strange segment from
this interview.
Speaker 5: Any Western nation or any nation
intervenes with this Russian military action.
Speaker 4: Well, this is something that should
have never happened.
This would not have happened during my administration.
In fact, some people were saying, Why didn't
this take place take place over the last four
years during our administration?
And it didn't for a very good reason.
Then explain that to you someday.
Speaker 1: But very soon the evidence is going
to come forward about why this invasion did
not take place.
One day, Trump will explain why it didn't
take place under his watch unhinged, unhinged,
global laughingstock.
The level of aggression.
Of Putin is matched only by the level of ignorance
of Donald Trump.
At the same time as this invasion is going
on